There's one map
you have to see to understand
this conflict between Hamas and Israel.
Gaza is this small strip of land
that has 2 million
Palestinians living in it.
After a short war in the ‘60s
Israel captured a bunch of land.
The map went from looking like this
to this.
Israel eventually
gave Sinai back to Egypt,
but they continued to occupy
this small strip of land called Gaza.
In 2005,
Israel withdrew from Gaza
and turned it over to the authority
of the Palestinians.
It was quickly taken over by this
anti-Israel group called Hamas,
which gets us back to this map.
As soon as Hamas took over Israel
and to lesser
extent, Egypt started controlling
everything that went in
and out of this strip.
So since Hamas has launched
these rocket land and sea attacks,
Israel has used this blockade
to cut off the 2 million
Palestinians living here
from fuel, food and supplies.
Their power plant has run out of gas
and it is a horrible
humanitarian situation.
All of this is yet another chapter
in this decades long
pattern of Israeli
occupation and Palestinian resistance,
much of it peaceful,
but some of it like this
horrifically violent.